this was how many Sri Lankans could
participate in the 75th Independence Day
Celebrations their money paid for from
the sidelines watching as the military
bans and marching squads left the parade
area
approach roads and the venue were locked
down hours ahead to ensure the
celebrations were not disrupted by
protesters people here are angry at
their government for spending hundreds
of thousands of dollars to put on this
event at a time when the nation is
struggling to pay for essential supplies
president Ryan Vikram singer insists the
celebration is important
addressing the nation he said the
corrupt political gangsterism which
cheats people into being eternally poor
and dependent must be defeated
he said this was the system change the
younger generation has been demanding
for a long time
my government has entered A New
reformist Path in order to do this even
though the decisions made towards this
seem painful these have to be taken in
order to get out of this crisis
his promises
the student leader has been released on
bail after being detained for 167 days
in what many see as political
persecution for his role in the 2022
anti-government protests
like the freedom struggle to liberate
the country from the imperialist 75
years ago we now have to struggle to
free the country from the robbers or the
thiefing gangs that corrupted this
Society for more than 70 years
hundreds of University students and
activists joined bundaligay to protest
against the government's Crackdown on
descent and spending
this despite a peaceful City being
violently broken up by police on Friday
night who said the protesters were
violating a court order Banning the
protests acclaimed lawyers disputed many
here say the government should not be
spending this much money to put on
Military parades while millions of Sri
Lankans are struggling to feed
themselves those organizing protests
like this say they will continue their
campaign until the country is truly free
of corruption Fernandez Al Jazeera
Colombo